our protesters have clashed with police
in Kenya's Capital Nairobi during
demonstrations against the government's
plans to raise taxes there
the opposition Coalition is calling for
three days of protests Over The Soaring
cost of living the new taxes were due to
take effect at the beginning of this
month but a court in Nairobi had halted
their implementation pending further
legal proceedings Kenyan President
William Ruto has called on his
supporters to hold counter-protests well
let's bring in Catherine soy she joins
us now from Nairobi Catherine I
understand that these demonstrations
have been growing what have you been
seeing there on the streets
yes there's been a lot of uncertainty
um all week and right now we are on
opposition area police have been
throwing tear gas and the protesters on
the other and have been using uh stones
and slings and things like that our
crowd around the country we have talked
to people who are saying that there are
some demonstrations going on as well but
not as heavily as what is happening and
here and a lot of people are decided to
stay away particularly in the city
center we know that shops have been
closed we also know that government
schools have been told to stay home
until to wait out the situation
we have also been following uh very
keenly Railroad dinga the opposition
leader he's the one who has called these
protest for this protests he has told
people to come to the streets carrying
pots and pans to symbolize
um this very High Cost of Living people
here are very frustrated they're saying
that they want the cost of living
reduced they are very angry about this
Finance act that now is in um in court
so people are frustrated but it is still
very few fluid ended Catherine we know
that the government has previously used
not only tear gas as you're seeing now
but also live rounds and trying to
control protests what kind of security
deployment are you seeing around the
capital I can see right there behind you
that military vehicle
foreign
deployment of security forces not just
in Nairobi but in different parts of the
country as well and I've told you as I
told you
um the police are using tear gas and we
also have seen uh in previous uh
protests police have used uh very big
Force to deal with protesters we know
that several people have been killed in
the last two weeks or so some of them
were shot uh the government has been
blamed the police have been blessed we
have thus received a statement from a
human rights or organizations especially
Human Rights Watch that have condemned
the police
brutality as well so the police right
now it seems that they are really
holding themselves we haven't seen any
uh Unbecoming issues but and there is an
issue the people are afraid of that
these protests should they escalate the
things may get worse and they're indeed
meant to continue for three days
Catherine Sawyer in the Kenyan capital
for us in Nairobi thank you so much
Catherine